wir haben ja heute ganz viele große
themen immer wo sich und sagte immer
aufgeregt wird und es ist eigentlich
alles furchtbar und sobald irgendeiner
jetzt in irgendeiner art und weise sich
nicht abgeholt fühlt dann wird natürlich
gleich großer terror gemacht und quasi
die anderen die das gesagt dann sind
wahrscheinlich dann auch fast schon
extremisten und wie können sie das nur
sagen und wie geht das eigentlich früher
hat man ja sowieso ich sage mal auch
politisch du weißt es ja selbst man hat
quasi debattiert egal welche partei man
isst man hat über irgendwelche themen
gesprochen in der familie bei freunden
in der eckkneipe überall und danach hat
man bier getrunken und zwar eine die
alles wieder in ordnung heute ist das ja
ganz anders heute wird ja sofort denn
quasi nein du bist jetzt darf gar nicht
mehr mitspielen weil du hast dich gar
nicht ging an die regeln gehalten und so
geht es ganz und ich finde quasi dass
wir heute in einem land sind wo man
einen grund nahm gar nicht mehr wirklich
sagen da fasst man jetzt denkt und ich
sag mal so wir leben ein ende der
demokratie ich bin auch sehr froh
darüber dass wir dort leben aber es wir
sind so empfindlich geworden